this tiny little wafer-thin ship could
be a better way to explore space than
this in the gold rush to space you could
say we're like the shovel once upon a
time Natalia Bailey had big dreams of
working for NASA I would sleep on my
trampoline at night and watch the stars
and thinking about aliens and watching
the space station pass overhead and I
you know went on to apply to NASA twice
to become an astronaut and I've gotten
the thanks but no thanks postcards from
NASA but I'll keep applying so she had
to settle for being a plain old rocket
scientist and a founding member of
accion systems a startup poised to
revolutionize space travel would these
wafer thin chips that Believe It or Not
our engines low-earth orbit is becoming
more and more accessible to
organizations universities hobbyists in
their garages people that before never
would have even imagined launching a
satellite so we're talking about you
know tens of thousands of satellites
being launched over the next decade and
currently they have no propulsion
solutions and that's what accion is
building is is an ion engine that works
on small satellites okay this is
actually rocket science so here's the
bare minimum you need to know an ion is
a charged atomic particle by pushing
ionic liquid which is basically a molten
salt into this ship the size of a pinion
billions of ions can be discharged at
mind-boggling velocities if you could
picture an astronaut sitting on the back
of a satellite and she's throwing tennis
balls off the back each time she throws
a tennis ball off the satellite moves a
little bit in the opposite direction in
accion's engine these tennis balls are
actually ions and our smallest ion
engine is about the size of a pack of
cards now we'll still need conventional
rockets to escape Earth's gravity
once in space accion ship will increase
the shelf life of satellites by years
and eventually enable deep space travel
without chemical propulsion rockets our
engines operate without any fire
you know flames or loud noises so
they're not quite as visceral as say a
falcon heavy rocket for example but
they're very efficient this is a brick
hoot the canard pusher and it's kind of
like our family car I've always wanted
to be an astronaut and aviation is kind
of like the next best thing
fortunately I married a pilot and we're
raising the youngest pilot here
[Music]
the first electric propulsion engines
were actually developed in the 50s and
60s but they were largely ignored after
that and it seemed to me during college
that there was this whole branch of
rocket science just waiting to be
advanced
Natalia's studies accelerated at such a
rapid pace she had to learn what it
meant to own a business while still a
student of science
I don't think business comes naturally
to me I was in a lab at MIT trying to
finish up experiments with headphones on
listening to how to be a start-up CEO
and trying to learn on the job
essentially our serious long-term
customers are right now people like the
Department of Defense and folks like
Lockheed Martin and Boeing but our first
flight delivery that went out the door
was actually to Irvine high school so a
group of high school students is going
to be launching a CubeSat with our
system on it after Hawking these ships
to everyone from school kids to the
Department of Defense natalia envisions
accion playing an even larger role in
space exploration
Mars or Alpha Centauri pretty Abby hug
big hairy audacious goal is that sort of
like your whole career everything yes
why would you have it any other way
you
you